hi guys in this video I'm going to show you
how to get rid of hip pain now you can do this
on yourself or your going to you might need some
help to have someone do it on you so let me show
you how to fix hip pain alright guys I'm going
to show you how to get rid of hip pain so let's
pretend that she has right-sided hip pain now
the pelvis is right from here down to here and
the hip is right in the center so if she has hip
pain on the right side we're going to press on
the opposite side the left side now what you're
going to do is you're going to do three things
you're going to press on the opposite mirror
image side and just massage this now if you
were going to do it you could take a tennis ball
or a racket ball and lay it on this side do not
press on the side that hurts work on the opposite
side and this is something they don't tell you or
teach you in school but it works like magic so
what we want to do is want to press on that hip
and really stimulate it now the opposite mirror
image side the where the pain is is going to be
very tender so go light and you'll be surprised
how tender this is but the way we know we got the
exact opposite spot is the tenderness so we're
trying to find the epicenter of where the most
tenderness is and we're going to work that out and
you know just massage it for like two minutes okay
that's step one now step two is we're going to go
we work on the muscle that's attached to the hip
so you got hip as hip joint as a joint and it's
a bone connected with another bone but there's
a lot of muscle attachments with that so what
we want to do if she hurts over here we want to
work on the muscle that's above the hip okay and
it's like right up in here and it's like right in
there and there's going to be a little muscle
above that hip that you're going to just work
out it'll be very tight and very sore okay let's
step to work on that muscle massage it again you
could you could take foam roller and work on that
area you can strip all the way down here as well
which is not a bad idea to work on this thigh but
then what we want to do is the hip comes up right
here we want to work on the inside of the abdomen
and massage this point on the opposite side with
a hip pain is why because on this side there's a
muscle that is on the inside of your spine that
attaches to this leg right here and it's called
the iliopsoas muscle and what you're going to do
is going to press down in there and it's going to
be really tender so you want to gently work out
all the soft tissue on this side all the way down
to here okay so we're working on the opposite side
of the hip the muscle just above and the muscle
right through and here okay so those are the three
steps to get rid of hip pain now if this doesn't
work then we know that the pain is referred from
usually if it's a female the ovary the ovary if
there's a cyst on it will refer pain on that side
of the hip or the hip bone in the back is called
the sacroiliac joint so in that case what you want
to do is give the person some sea kelp because
seek help gets rid of cysts faster than anything
I know so because it's missing iodine iodine
reduces estrogen and that's where it's coming
from it's estrogen dominance so again these are
just there's different causes of hip pain and it
also could be an injury as well but go ahead and
apply this technique and make your comments below